yeah that is the reaction of champion
Magnus Carlson who realized he just
missed a very simple tactic which might
change the outcome of the
game well how did this happen what
exactly Magnus missed let's check them
out in the 12th round of
2023 World Blitz Championship Magnus had
black pieces against the former world
Championship Challenger Yan napom
Nishi after the mu4 Carlson opted for
the caroan defense with
C6 and we quickly reached to the tatac
cover variation that start with Knight
to F6 NX F6 and now eex
F6 both the side has continued with some
obvious
continuation and we have reached to the
critical position when black took the kn
Knight and then played the move F5 here
after some thinking Napo choos the move
C5 which is obviously a huge
mistake however Carlson was not
particularly switched on and after just
thinking about it for five six seconds
he quickly dropped his Bishop back on E7
which turned out as a counter
mistake the whole tactical point in this
variation is that black can actually
take this pH and get a healthy Point
Advantage for the rest of the
game how let's find out well of course
if white doesn't capture the bishop then
black e is a clear Pawn up so how about
taking this bishop now and I guess now
you see it the answer is very simple
black initiate the queen trade and at
the end you get your piece back at the
E2 Square where if you count the
material not only black emerged with a
clear PA Advantage but if you look at
the engine Evolution here it's clearly
favoring the black with minus two and
especially at that level and for Magnus
this can be a huge
Factor later on the game fizzled out as
a draw and after the game when Magnus
was discussing with nappo his opponent
pointed out the mistake he made and as
soon as Carlson realized it he was
shocked and disgusted that he had missed
a big time
[Music]
opportunity so this proves that even
Sometimes the best in the world missed a
simple
[Music]
tactics